now you've helped us film like our
drifting special we're drifting yeah
yeah we unfortunately like didn't get a
proper chance to introduce you in that
episode
and you you were just kind of just kind
of just showed up
very scuffed very slip shot i i i don't
know what i was expecting some sort of
grand entrance we talked about me like
rocking up in a car and be like
hey everyone in the end
all abroad no it's nothing in the back
of the
opening shot was just dying in the back
of the car while joey was in the front
really glad i got involved with that
project it's like a really quick pandas
but that was a lot of fun it was
honestly nice to be behind
the camera yeah um watching joey be sick
and
it's great it is nice shooting someone
else's video because you're like if this
[ __ ] up not my problem
yeah if it all goes wrong i'm good it's
fun just like flying the drone i was
trying to crash it into the car
like yeah i wanted you to yes yeah when
you were like like
charging towards yeah yeah yeah do you
like do you like being behind the camera
like more than in front of the camera or
vice versa
i do i like being behind the camera
i do prefer being behind the camera
really i'm way more conscious of how i'm
presenting and you know it's just fun
filming but presenting
it's tough like i get the impression you
prefer presenting more than filming
right
oh no i i mean i prefer being in like
the producer director role
where i can just tell people what to do
and i have like a vision of my project
rather than
being on the project itself um i am
awful representing i think and that's
why these two are on camera more than me
i don't i just don't think i have enough
experience behind the camera
right to really know if i like being
behind the camera more than in front of
it
i do like presenting but it really
stresses me out when you're also
presenting the director the producer
like everything is like
everyone's like looking at you for
direction it's like well i can't do
everything come on give me a hand
yeah cause you know some shoots
obviously rock up to and like they're
like sort of your plan card i'm like i
don't know
what do you mean we were just gonna
start filming stuff like i have no idea
and then it's a bit hard to present
because it's like this is a
coffee in this cafe and it's just kind
of
awkward it's like how your videos go
it's like yeah we'll fix it in post
we'll fix it in post
i just like to imagine like that's how
you are on the actual filming day and
then somehow in post it just turns into
hey guys welcome back there are lots of
moments where i'm like i'll just say
something and then obviously
it just cuts into a smooth transition
voiceover what actually happens is i
just say something and i'm like
why is that good real good everyone's
just like looking at me confused i'm
like all right we'll just do the next
thing we're going to the next thing
yeah yeah that's that's what that's what
i learned from the akbar episode that we
did where
it was my first time actually filming
out in the open and
i because i i didn't know when to stop
talking
like when a sentence is fine you can
come up when no one's directing you i
wasn't used to just being like
okay silence is is that good did we cut
there uh do i keep talking i don't know
did i present enough information
i guess yeah because all of the all of
gigs videos are scripted right yeah yeah
so it's like a completely different
experience
being like well i know if it's scripted
where to pause
i thought about this you you do get used
to though i think
eventually just being like all right the
camera's always on it's whatever right
i'll just relax when i'm done saying
what i need to say
yeah but i think when you initially have
it you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm being
recorded fbi is going to get this
footage
i'm still not used to filming in public
i feel like i don't i can do videos like
off script because i've done you know
stuff i've done on script stuff but when
it's outside with just
random people watching me i feel there's
like a weird pressure of like oh people
are
probably watching me judging me yeah and
i can't
because so like that's why i could never
understand people who have the balls to
like
walk out you know in the middle of
shinjuku or whatever and just start
vlogging by themselves i don't know how
people do that i i think that's why i
like i like getting permission because
when i found permission i feel like it's
the green light oh yeah
yeah exactly when there's no permission
though i kind of have to you know just
be like
they don't find it i hate secretly yeah
but i [ __ ] like
when you did your recent amazing video
series chris
really great stuff uh your journey to
mount fuji right
journey to mount fuji what is it called
i just watched someone
you're amazing serious i don't remember
the name what was that again it's
just across japan escape to fiji [ __ ]
hell chris that's a mouthful
come on youtube seo needs to be i like
how you went like the proper sequel
title
yeah yeah my journey across japan
escaped the future
ocean i was running because you filmed
in daiso did you have to ask them before
or just rock up with the cameras
fun fact one of the only places in japan
you can film without needing permission
really
[Music]
i know there's a silence like pictures
are okay but i don't know if that means
rock up with your film crew and go
inside and start
this is chris broad and here is a
plastic hand
for 300 years
like david attenborough i just because
in my head chris
sounds way more british than he is right
so i i think like
what do you mean he's the most british
man alive no no no no he's not
come on connor's accent is more british
than mine really from wales
what does that work i don't know there's
people who watch me who say the uh the
opposite they say that i don't sound
british enough and that you sound proper
british
because chris broad's voice and abroad
in japan's voice i feel like two
different voices
they definitely like your presenting
accent is a lot more british i feel then
yeah your just regular talking accent
i don't know i don't know i don't know i
feel like i've known you long enough
now i just get lost when you start
talking i know when you're in like
presenter mode i think yeah when i'm
presenter i'm more cynical sarcastic and
unpleasant
which is not like that in real life [ __ ]
off
you're like that normally yeah i was
thinking i'm supposed to say it
unbelievable it was fun because when we
filmed the
the drifting video and we were in the
hotel i was like oh my god chris is just
like
exactly like me just absolutely [ __ ]
chris is just [ __ ]
miserable and complains about everything
oh my god it's exactly the same i mean
that's just the most british trait yeah
that's like all british too that's just
any brick
that's just any brit who goes abroad
right
and that's why brits rarely go like
abroad to places that other brits
haven't already been to yeah
like hearing hearing about a brit who
goes to asia we're like the weird ones
to be fair that's true that's true
normally we just stick in europe or like
[ __ ]
zanti or one of the [ __ ] islands
right i don't [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is
zanzi
that's one of the [ __ ] islands
there's a bunch of party i love ibiza
they just sound like game of thrones
locations to me like it's better though
the island of sandy what is this you've
given me
it's it's cheap it's
this is like my first time to drink it
yeah so i'm a bit nervous the way you're
looking at me
are you gamified now are you having like
a trip
it's delicious what is it it's like
fizzy it's not fizzy but it's like
really sour and
it's like an especially like an energy
drink i don't know what flavor you have
pink lemonade oh you have pink lemonade
pink lemonade does it do something
like it energizes you chris why don't
you into an epic game again when i saw
maylene pouring it she was like
[Music]
you're going to enjoy this i mean that's
that's just that's just me
that's just me that's mailing with
anything